I'm very much looking forward to that
yeah let's let's see some Rubenstein
because uh yesterday when I when I
brought up that story of Georg Meyer
just publishing his files to prevent
people from playing
specific line of the Rubenstein against
him uh so that people don't bore him
Chad was saying the other way not to get
bored is not to play the Rubenstein at
all which is sort of fair
but on the other hand it is surprisingly
sharp if white wants it
there's we have it on the board yeah
there's definitely some lines in
Rubinstein where play could become very
very concrete and very very sharp so uh
it is absolutely not a given that this
will be uh some kind of a some kind of a
boring game not at all and C3 is played
immediately she three she three exists
but I'm I'm a little bit curious about
this like what are we trying to achieve
compared to uh to Knight F3 it's
difficult for me to imagine uh the the
G1 Knight being developed to any Square
other than of three if we're having some
issues we're having some issues those
are those are the the breaks um
yes exactly I I just can't play them
yeah I can see you trying to play Bishop
D3 and the the machine telling you no uh
which is a bit a bit frustrating but I'm
sure we'll figure it out you immediately
hit me with C5 and I didn't know what to
do yeah exactly and I was going to say
we're also
now we have the option of putting the
bishop on C2 instead of D3 which is
maybe a little bit better Gerard figure
it out although he still is playing
quite quickly and honestly knowing Georg
it's very possible that he's looked at
C3 at some point in his life while we're
also watching uh the the footage from
the playing Hall we discussed it
yesterday when the playing pole was
empty and it was even more obvious but
this is a very nice uh you know spacious
uh spacious Hall plenty of space between
the boards which is very important
slightly different uh French uh that he
got against Magnus this is still I
believe a theoretical position but with
the bishop on D3 right so the difference
is uh the bishop is on C2 which I guess
if black plays naively like if you
Castle here for instance yeah and Bishop
G5 you play something solid like
uh weird that
what's happening oh yeah so Bishop G5
Bishop G7 you want to play Bishop C6 you
want to play Queen D5 something like
that and now I play Queen D3
and now there is a difference between
the bishop on D3 and the bishop on C2
a pretty large difference this position
might be just straight up bad for black
now because I think maybe the best move
is rookie age is giving up the pawn H7
was check uh because otherwise I have to
play G6 maybe and that's even worse uh
but Maya still quite quickly uh plays a
B7 B6 which is an interesting move
considering that you can't really play
Bishop B7 with the King on E8 right
because Bishop A4 check will be painful
what will black do after after the move
like Bishop A4 check later the bishop B7
what did Magnus do Magnus opted for
Queen D3 yeah
yeah instead of visual G5 which I think
is a more flexible choice because it it
gives your options more open uh castling
is still completely unplayable because
of Bishop G5
uh but we're also kind of hinting maybe
at Queen G3 which could be a very
awkward move for black to face in some
situations wow okay that's that's thank
you very much because as a commentator
with all these games sporting gay for
lucasd and knowing that this is so
important it's almost impossible yeah
yeah and also just to highlight that
yeah it's very important that the timing
get it after 25 we have a look GST
protecting attacking at the same time
and and thanks to this white is having
the upper if 25 was forcing us to play
F3 this entire idea is dead but we're
just in time to uh to play rog3 here and
yeah black black seems to be in uh
indecent amount of trouble actually
Bishop okay for checking if it finally
was played Bishop D2 H5 a very typical
so he chose this way to finish
development he goes H5 Magnus completely
ignores that he goes H4 of course
ignoring H3 would be strange so he goes
yeah H3 is and now black has the option
of playing Rook H5 and
uh bringing that Rook into the game wire
via that square yeah
so it was not only we who didn't know
exactly how to treat this position yeah
yeah the eight
lucky one king G8 Bishop E3 wow I mean
I'm actually liking Black's position
yeah I think black is completely fine I
mean you have to pay attention that like
in some end games the pawn H4 could
become a Target but we are very very far
away from any end game for now down to
70 minutes versus 22 it will escalate it
will lead to some big time scramble yeah
absolutely wow okay so even this
structure change happened and finally
the look is out of the box
but the garage is not an easy opponent
for Magnus I guess you actually start
with Bishop G4 because like if you play
Bishop 3 here I take I go e65
I want to claim that maybe black is even
a little bit better
so I would like to provoke a five
so that
in the same position the pawn and F5
will be hanging
yeah and if he's down to a minute yeah
if something if he needs to calculate
something then
I mean he still has King H7 it's not
like he blunder Rook f8 check clearly I
mean it's uh it's still still kind of
fine Rook d8 queen d8 queen of five
check I guess we just go
you can even go King H6 if you want I
suppose yeah it's on the board yeah okay
but but girl glossy stability yeah
yeah this is definitely this is
definitely not uh you know the cleanest
way to to make this is exactly what you
should never do against Magnus I mean
yeah he might play a little before
coming
ever untangle yeah it's very annoying
it's just very very annoying because
yeah it's it's so difficult to make
moves but yeah Magnus goes queen of five
chairs okay I mean I'm most curious like
the the biggest question for me is what
if if you want to play five why you're
not playing E5 here why are you waiting
for ud3 Queen after yes what is what is
going on is is girl surviving
it's going to be very similar to the
line that we were just showing I think
it's going to be very very and
apparently for for some reason we don't
actually have access to uh to that
camera and I want to point out that uh
sort of as in a kind of a additional
annoyance for for Georg
if let's say the Queens get traded on
the G5 square and black has to take with
the King for instance like Queen of
seven check here I want to give a sample
line it's not forced like Queen F4 Queen
G5
we take yeah let's go to NFA check here
it's cleaner yeah queen f8 king H5 which
give a check from h8 we trade on H6
and we go to C7 this actually wins the
port
I mean I assume it's a draw
and yeah marvelous just makes a quiet
move here just goes Queen F4 without uh
without giving any more checks which is
yeah this is why I wanted to play King
H6 though yeah from happening yeah and
now you're just sitting there panicking
because you can't find the move yeah and
let's just show the difference yeah that
Knight Queen G5 is met by check listen
to you just getting my checkmated
because the roof got the C7 with a check
and you no longer have this H5 Square so
I'm guessing you have to play something
like King G8 right now
and hope that after Rook C7 have some
kind of Perpetual but you don't maybe
you're just lost no no I think with this
time situation it's it's basically game
over yeah I just don't uh maybe you
actually have to play like Rook D3 Rook
D7 and give up the pawn which Focus
check
and uh I mean if you know at least that
you can get to Queen sand game maybe
it's it's oh yeah obviously played yeah
he had to because everything else looked
inadequate I think what we should
practically explain that actually black
is very lucky to wear the pawn on G6
because this Pawn on G6 gives a nice
shatter for black skin yeah so black
will be able to hide on H7 on the other
hand if this Pawn would not be on G6 but
it would be on A7 or H6 then black would
always have a big big club with his King
yeah I mean yeah anything can happen in
these two can games yeah absolutely and
the position on our screen is actually
kind of surprising to me because
uh this looks like a very comfortable
draw in fact I
I'm too lazy to check but I would
suggest that it very easily could be a
draw without the pawn on defy
and there is still a Pawn on B5 on the
board so
uh yeah looks like Magnus is probably
not winning today I don't think I've
seen very many and it's still possible
to lose them you know people lose all
kinds of seemingly very simple positions
like if they get to like G5 and H5 and
you still don't have an immediate
Perpetual I'm not sure all of those are
still a draw I mean obviously Magnus
will continue pushing but yeah I think
as long as as long as York doesn't lose
his uh doesn't lose his school here he
should hold very very comfortably it's a
bit scary to make a move without the
chat which leaves the bottom B5
unprotected but white cannot connect to
it without access to the e-files so like
Queen F7 we can even go King H6
and then if white has to play G4 we have
checks from from below now Queen H1
Queen exactly and so forth and I can't
really expect uh minus to really pose
any problems and and he calls G4 so what
does it mean that he is willing to to
well that's that's basically a draw for
now G4 Queen H1 Check Yes
I'm trying to understand what Magnus has
in mind I think he's just he knows it's
a draw so he basically is offering a
draw Because unless no no like King H2
sorry King H4 we go Queen H2
King F5 queen of two my question is
after queen of two King E6 can I take on
the F6 or not yeah but afterwards there
is also the other scenario that's
suddenly out of tiredness or some some
blindness you you blunder something yeah
actually B5 B4 on the board by the way
yeah that why on Earth did I want to
calculate when I had no reason to
calculate okay I mean it will be an
incredible Save By by girl but he to be
honest he caused his trouble to himself
yeah he was absolutely fine comfortable
no reason to to to have those scary
moments but he survived them and seems
to
seems to be safe King G3 queen of two
and then the king isn't he is in the uh
is in the corner right you
you just ah because he he gave not Queen
H1 check I mean
yeah Ah that's the thing yeah he chose
not to even yeah Queen H1 was an
immediate draw because that's not an
option you you no longer have that
option but he gave it yet from here and
that gave Magnus this choice of playing
uh yeah and just to highlight that yeah
this case
yeah that would be a bit of a mistake
yes
check
so King G8 just to highlight that King
H6 the active will runs into Checkmate
in G5 that would be terrible so of
course yeah black goes back with the
King to Jade I'm guessing you choose you
choose any Square I think both of them
are fine yeah it's a matter of taste
which one which one you prefer shouldn't
matter don't see any way to get mated so
I'm just wow but look at this girl even
goes King each eight yeah yeah also
completely fine yeah yeah Magnus
continues in my spirit yeah th5 put the
poker face on like I'm starting
something yeah I mean okay signal and
then the girl is down to a minute yeah
uh do we maybe have the
the video oh yeah there it is yeah we
could maybe actually just
yeah your goes B2 and yeah I think
Magnus kind of has to pull the plug now
because if you like if you make a quiet
move here and the beep on Queens you
know you you really feel tremendously
stupid yeah no of course okay Magnus can
maybe try to get his Queen to B7 we
check yeah so that he but how do you get
there yeah that's awesome yeah there you
go yeah okay Queen E4 and now can he
play G5 after king h8 without allowing
the the pawn to Queen he probably can
actually huh Queen f7s damn it the the
queen against Luke and and second king
eight shade king h8 white can play King
G6 here
and you hear and you have to give up the
pawn
oh my God yeah oh whoa whoa whoa and
apparently
apparently King G8 was completely drawn
but King h8 now Magnus will play King G6
and I mean hang on what what is the big
difference
I have no idea I mean hang on that is is
the queen G7 check and stalemate the
idea if it's Kingdom all right oh my God
show it you we have to show it to the
viewers yes I mean let me get this yeah
that's so cute yeah if the King goes
back to G then after King G6 we have
this this kind of stand mate idea Queen
G7 takes and then B1 Queen and if Queen
F5 we make play Queen E4 or what yeah we
just yeah we we can continue
wow
yeah and then Magnus goes King G6 yeah
that that's exactly the reason why we
were saying like Okay just calculate the
fourth line till the end just don't give
all these practical chances yeah and we
I think judging by the evaluation B1 is
still a draw uh because it says like 160
and I think 160 in this position is not
enough
but I think this one Magnus actually
probably wins because
now he can play Forever and York is on
20 seconds and there is no Force draw
because
as far as I can tell there is no at
least no immediate Perpetual it's just
still a draw because as we know G and H
just doesn't win against
the King on h8 with precise computer
play but yeah I mean try showing precise
computer play on 20 seconds against the
world champion what
he played Queen C6 Queen C6 check yeah
exactly
it's clearly yeah I believe I'm
corrected I will put it there I guess
we'll just watch it full screen because
we're not going to be we're not going to
be uh able to analyze it properly so if
we can just full screen the full screen
the board it would be good so what this
does is just make you sit there kind of
hating life and waiting for something to
finally happen
and it just makes you more and more
nervous and makes you less and less sure
about what's going on
let's create a check possibility
and and yeah let's not forget that gag
is now in a State of Shock it was not
planned that he has to give up the
people and He will absolutely yeah he
wanted to use that phone to guarantee
also also incredibly cute variation here
because the machine goes 25 check this
one we can maybe show on the screen 25
queen of 5 Queen G8 it looks like it's
an immediate blunder because Queen F6
check and then we have King H7 wow
which is uh once again like how easy is
this and he's already not chosen the
square which means that after Queen F5
he can no longer give a check from this
diagonal like he he gave a check from C5
and now Queen E7 actually does lose
because there will be no stalemates
um and I'm not sure if this is a draw
anymore
hits it yeah apparently this is now gone
for some reason yeah I don't know why
I give up
foreign
for some reason yeah queen of four uh
Queen C5 and you just go King G6 and uh
the checks actually run out
so he had to see he actually had to see
the
the queen D5 d8 King H7 trick yeah it
was basically impossible because as we
as we said he was in a state of shokia
yeah this is just over now because
Quincy took in a five and you run out of
checks and you have to allow Queen F6
check and you resign
yeah and you can see on the body
language of magnusia is very pleased and
gag designs
wow
yeah very very dramatic finish to this
game because Georg defended really
really well but as we were like after
after Magnus played G2 G4 we kept on
saying that
you really should try to invest the time
in making sure that this is the last
calculation you do in the game and he
had the knob he had a very very clean
Force draw at that moment he chose not
to even
uh look for it and uh
ended up it ended up costing him costing
him the game